this morning we are hearing from
survivors who were packed inside a
sweltering tractor-trailer with no air
conditioning and no water they were in
this 18-wheeler as it traveled to San
Antonio Texas one survivor linked a
Mexican drug cartel to the smuggling
operation 10:10 immigrants have died
dozens are in the hospital today James
Bradley the truck driver faces charges
that could result in the death penalty
mark Strassmann is in San Antonio where
the truck was found mark good morning
good morning survivors have described
their desperation and panic riding in
the back of that pitch-black overheated
trailer the special agent-in-charge I
spoke to didn't want to talk about the
criminal investigation but he did tell
us that the appalling way in which these
people were transported is not uncommon
when an Lara Vega and six people climbed
into the back of the trailer in Laredo
Texas he says it was pitch black and
already full an hour into the trip Vega
says people started crying and asking
for water as the trailer got hotter he
says people fell into despair
investigators estimate more than 100
people were packed inside the truck
temperatures climbed well above 100
degrees people shared a single breathing
hole in the wall in court papers another
survivor says he traveled with a group
of nearly 30 people rafting across the
Rio Grande and paying more than $700 for
protection to the Mexican Zetas drug
cartel
Shane Fulton is the special agent in
charge for homeland security
investigations in San Antonio these
organizations consider these people
simply a commodity they don't think of
them as people they look at them from a
profit perspective on Monday the driver
of the semi trailer 60 year old James
Matthew Bradley made his first
appearance in federal court he faces a
charge of illegally transporting
immigrants for financial gain resulting
in death Bradley told investigators he
did not know anyone was in the back of
the 18-wheeler until he parked at the
San Antonio Walmart to use the restroom
and he heard noise coming from the
trailer he says when he opened the doors
he was run over by Spanish people and
knocked to the ground he then noticed by
just lying on the floor like meat our
goal isn't just to arrest the individual
transporting these people our goal is
really to dismantle the organization
bradley entered no plea in court if
convicted he could face the death
penalty
several dozen survivors escaped into
nearby woods
the feds hope to coax those people out
of hiding to get needed medical
treatment and also helped build this
criminal case charlie mark thank you